Latvians Minister of Foreign Affairs is
in London meeting members of the cabinet
for discussions about the future of his
country's relationship with the UK in
the post briggsie era one area of
concern for Edgerrin kovitch is the
right of Latvian nationals to remain in
Britain secondly there's the role of
NATO as he's been telling me I'm here to
discuss three issues one is brexit
second is security and so normally as
foreign minister who comes to other NATO
and still the new country we discuss a
lot of issues that are related with our
immediate concerns Eastern neighborhood
Russia Ukraine and so on and I'm here
also to say that we want to have
negotiations over brexit that are
conducted in constructive manner and
what I have retreated here in London as
well as in Brussels meeting chief EU
negotiator we don't want any kind of
punishment of you okay that's something
we consider totally unacceptable and
that's also our position within EU will
it help if the UK were now to guarantee
nationals including the hundred thousand
nationals Latvian national sewer here
guarantee that they can stay obviously I
think it's very important that people
who live here who work here as well as
British nationals who live and work in
the European Union get this guarantee as
soon as possible because I think that
those people who are living either in UK
or in EU
they shouldn't suffer from whatever
politics we can sometimes play I mean
you're citizens here do they have things
changed it's a brexit vote for them well
just after referendum we received our
embassy received some information some
calls
they have been some kind of you know
splash off what normally is referred to
the kind of hate speech there were some
insults but now I'm hearing that
actually that kind of number or level of
incidents has come down I'm going to
meet of course also our
a community here representatives of our
community I'm going to discuss also such
kind of things but I'm pleased also that
cabinet ministers Secretary of State for
Brick City hers
David Davis has explicitly said that UK
will do whatever hitting they power to
actually undone such kind of incidents
and we have agreed to continue close
cooperation if we have some kind of such
incidents that they will be investigated
by my authorities on the question of
security of course Latvia Baltic state
very much in the front line as far as
Russian expansionism or ambitions might
be do you think that the fact that
Britain is leaving the EU weakens that
Security Alliance through NATO no not at
all
first of all I think that the
reassurance we have got in prime
ministers may speech in the United
States when she was addressing
Republican retreat also my talks with
secretary Johnson with secretary Fallon
have shown very clearly that UK takes
NATO commitment very seriously
we are grateful also for UK taking the
lead role in Estonia British soldiers
will come for exercises to Latvia so I
think that this kind of concern we
frankly had before breaks it that it may
actually we can also you case kind of
stands within NATO those concerns have
been rushed away we see that NATO is
something that United Kingdom takes very
seriously and that's actually going to
be also some kind of congestion of
European security policy for UK but also
for us and and how would you assess the
level of threat to as a member of the
European Union a democratic country look
I think that the decisions that NATO
heads of state and government took in
Warsaw deployment of NATO battle groups
have decreased the possibility of a
military incident or attack I really
don't believe there is going to be
Russian attack and even if sometimes
press and academic circles love to play
kind of scenarios I think that Russia is
not going to do anything what concerns
the kind of you know military operation
or testing the NATO forces involved
whose has done in the Ukraine
wait a minute Ukraine is not NATO member
and let's look at this from the Russian
perspective they don't see this kind of
you know Baltic security problem they
understand that this is the NATO
territory and they are going to play
with the whole NATO but I think what we
should be aware is what we now refer as
hybrid threats or hybrid warfare cyber
attacks information campaigns mentoring
in elections and we have very important
elections this year in Europe France the
Netherlands Germany so I think that that
is something we have to actually find
the proper response and I spent quite a
lot of time discussing what would be our
proper responses with Secretary of
Defense and Secretary of State for
Foreign Affairs thank you very much
thank you very much
[Applause]